hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to would you rather now
I know it's been a while since the last
time I did this and I know you guys
didn't quite like the quiet version so
you'll be very happy to understand that
I will be answering these questions
loudly proudly and stupidly which is
exactly how I live my life so would you
rather always look eight months pregnant
or always have a black eye now I was
thinking about this one because it all
depends on whether or not you are
actually pregnant if I actually have to
live my life with an eight month-old
baby inside of me for the rest of my
days that doesn't seem too comfortable
because one I don't have a vagina and
two that's weird because it's basically
a parasite at that point and always
having a black eye doesn't seem too bad
but if I don't have a baby inside of me
which is a statement I never thought I'd
say in my life but if I don't have a
baby inside of me that means I just have
a beer belly
a perfectly orb-like beer belly that
people love to come up and hug for some
strange reason but if I always have a
black eye does that mean that someone's
coming out to me and always punching me
in the face and random points throughout
my life because I imagine it heal
otherwise I just have a black tattoo
around my eye so I kind of got to go
with the black eye because at least I've
had a fighting chance unless it's just
perpetual and lessen just a beer belly
but the alternative of having a baby
inside you that's constantly eight
months pregnant or having a bat black
black eye and someone punching me in the
face repeatedly I guess I go with the
face punching it at least make me
stronger I suppose would you rather be a
nerd or be a jock okay this is weird
because in high school I was kind of
splitting the line between the two of
these if I can find that old picture of
me from my teenage years the disastrous
picture that you will see here of me
riddled with acne this is just as I
started puberty and when I started
puberty I got really strong like
compared to everyone else I was very
muscular and I was very athletic I won
all the UH the Ironman competition that
we had to thethe test athleticism if I
could even say words properly so I was
both a band
nerd and a jock and I wasn't cool in any
regard so never what you can be a nerd
you could be cool or he can be a jock
and be cool but I wasn't either of those
I was in the middle and I was still very
uncool so I who's the least cool
muscular nerd you'd ever see in your
life so I guess I'd go with being a nerd
when you rather only speak in questions
or only speak in movie quotes I don't
know if I've answered this one before
but only speaking questions would be
constantly playing the game that whose
line is in any way plays where you have
to asking questions and I'd be really
good at that but if I was only speaking
in movie quotes I guarantee you that in
every movie ever made is enough to get
by especially considering that I could
do other languages in other movies I
could speak another lamp ooh I might not
know what I'm saying but if I actually
know the quotes and I might be able to
quote from other languages in other
movies and I guarantee there's been
enough and does this count whole movies
ooh I hope it doesn't count specific
home movies and it's just cropping up at
random and I start quoting very obscure
and risque AMPAS your home movies but
that's that's besides the point but I'm
gonna go with speaking only in movie
quotes because I'm pretty sure I could
formulate something that would allow me
to live would you rather fight Hulk
Hogan or fight Dwayne the rock Johnson
Wow considering that Hulk Hogan is a
little bit older now and Dwayne the rock
Johnson is still in his prime and very
strong I've seen him working out it's
terrifying and if I had to fight him I
would die I mean if I had to fight hole
Hogan I'd probably die if either these
were in a cage match with me and they
wanted to kill me dead I would die
horribly and deadliness but I'll take on
Hulk Hogan and hope that he just falls
over from old age would you rather get
hit by a bus or watched a loved one get
hit by a bus this isn't a question and
get hit by a bus I'll take that bus I'm
not gonna let a loved one get hit by a
bus for me if you were on a safari would
you rather have your foot stepped on by
an elephant or have your foot bitten by
a lion
okay who's to say that the Lions gonna
stop when he bites my foot I mean if my
foot stepped on by an elephant that
pretty much gone footy that it's not a
foot anymore it's a foot pancake it's
just a flat foot not a foot you can't
use that if it gets bitten my lion it
could still be usable if it's just one
bite but then again you got a lion on
your foot and who's to say he's not
gonna crawl up a little bit north and
nab on - something's more valuable to me
so at the risk of it being a consistent
lion attack and I can't stop him I'm
gonna go with the elephant and sacrifice
a foot cuz then I could get a cyborg leg
and hopefully not die from lion would
you rather lick the armpit of a sweaty
cab driver or eat the ear wax of an old
man who's never cleaned his ears I'm
going with the cab driver I mean it
can't be that bad compared to whatever
the hell horror shows in this old man's
ears uh would you rather be able to talk
to read what would you rather be able to
talk to read minds but you get a really
bad headache after you use it or be able
to fly bit you're afraid of heights um
if I have to think like that sentence is
in the blue one then I don't think I
want that power or I could fly and be
afraid if I I could conquer my fear of
heights this isn't that difficult I
could get by I think why is that fifty
fifty I mean it's not a crippling fear
it's something I'm a brave man well I'm
not a brave man if anything my horror
plate there's there anything to say
about it but you know I think I'd be
okay you're I'm just being honest with
myself I think I could conquer that to
be able to fly I'd rather not have a
migraine every time I want to know what
grandma's thinking would you rather be
dangled over the edge of a cliff or be
forced to public speak now good god I'm
public speak every day
I am master of public speak me and
public speak real good me and public
speak to you now um listen to me speak
public and you have
see words come out mouth and may not
cave man I'll do the public speak would
you rather overdose on every drug at the
same time or fall off a 100 storey
building either one is gonna dead yeah
so it doesn't matter what you choose
so I guess every drug there's a lot of
drugs are we talking only psychedelic
drugs because if this involves every
other drug - maybe the horrible cocktail
because you have both the the overdose
of the bad drugs and then you have an
overdose of the Cure drugs so it's like
a war going on in your body at the same
you probably just explode like to be
honest you just explode but maybe you'd
have the trip of a lifetime and I don't
think I want to fall off a hundred
storey building so I'll take the drugs I
don't know what its gonna do to me if
it's every drawer every drug every drug
that's a lot of drug that's death by
drug but it's it's gonna be a wild ride
into the grave would you rather not be
able to stop being serious or not be
able to stop joking that would be really
really horrible if you could never stop
joking like no one takes you seriously
at any point and I mean living your life
being so serious that you're pretty much
severus snape going through the world
not enjoying any sort of fun or joy or
happiness for that matter I guess I
would rather have my point across than
always being played for as a fool so
I'll take the not stop being serious Wow
it doesn't mean you're funny you might
be joking and not be funny at all would
you rather fight a crocodile with a bow
or fight an elephant with a shotgun okay
so if you shoot an elephant with a
shotgun all you're gonna do is piss it
off it's gonna get angrier and you're
gonna get better
that foot stopping that we were talking
about before forget all that
it's gonna turn into face stomping body
stopping and then ball stopping no
reverse that order it's gonna start with
ball stomping and then move on up to
your face if I fight a crocodile with a
bow
what kind of bow it is and how good it
is and how good my aim is at least I
have a fighting chance or I could run
away if an anthem green elephant is
charging after me I don't think I'm
gonna survive too long even if I did
have a shotgun I'll take the bow I want
to go out of bad ass I want to be a hero
damn it actually I'm just killing
animals is horrible would you rather
drink a gallon of mustard in one sitting
or use mustard as toothpaste for three
weeks there's no reward here what I mean
if you drink a gallon of mustard could
that kill you I have no idea if you're
gonna overdose on mustard it wouldn't be
pleasant that's for sure you can yeah I
don't think you can actually drink a
gallon of anything it's too much fluid
in your stomach so I think you just
explode in a horrible mustard accident
it'd be a Jackson Pollock painting of
mustard and blood and mucus inside your
house not good I'll take the toothpaste
is that can use normal toothpaste geez
would you rather have a very attractive
spouse that treats you badly
or have an ugly spouse that adores you
well this just depends on how vain you
are but I would never be in a
relationship where someone treats me
badly there's no way that's happening
would you rather would you rather be
chased by 100 rabid squirrels through a
flat open plane or go down a 200-foot
slide completely made out of ice
headfirst with your shirt off oh my nips
off oh my poor nips Oh God not my nips I
mean if it's a hundred rabid squirrels
they are faster than me so it doesn't
even matter if it's an open plane I'm
pretty sure squirrels faster than you oh
but my nips oh but my tender sweet nips
I'll risk the squirrels I'll get a
rabies shot afterwards not my nips Oh
God
would you rather stop using YouTube or
stop using Facebook stop using Facebook
I could never give up YouTube it's kind
of my life oh man would you rather
always disappoint people or always anger
people well this is just that thing that
your dad does where he says I'm not
angry
I'm just disappointed I mean if you're
angering people it doesn't mean that
you're wrong but if you're disappointing
people man that's just sad I'll go with
the angering people would you rather
have a conversation with Yoda for ten
minutes
or punch Jar Jar Binks for an hour now
I'm not a violent man but I have a funny
feeling I know what you guys are talking
about out there but if I can have a
conversation with Yoda I can get a lot
of wisdom out of that so I'll choose
wisdom over the satisfaction of beating
up Jar Jar Binks I wonder what other
people's oh god there's a surprising
number of people that would beat up Jar
Jar Binks
would you rather bathe in vomit or bathe
and work ah I'll take the worms but ah
okay so I've got a good question for you
guys to leave on that's gonna cause the
comments to rage uncontrollably would
you rather spend the day with Taylor
Swift or spend a day with Beyonce I'm
not wandering into pop culture so I
don't really care either way I don't
have an answer but I'll let you guys
decide down below thank you everybody so
much for watching and thank you so much
for helping me out and answering these
questions and enjoying my stupidity so
thanks again and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye
Blue is a metaphor